-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here
with Secretary Buttigieg.
You are unabashed about the fact
that you love transportation
and I agree with you,
that I think that,
you know,
travel is very romantic.
With that said,
I've spent a lot of time
in the O'Hare Airport
over the years,
and I never thought
it would be a place
where I would want to propose,
but that is, indeed,
where you proposed
to your husband, at O'Hare
[ Laughing ]
What was it about O'Hare?
-Yeah, I know
not everybody understands
that O'Hare
can be a romantic place,
[ Laughter ]
but it absolutely can.
So, the first time
Chaston and I ever communicate
was on this app called Hinge
and he was sitting at Gate B
at the airport.
He had a job that involved
helping exchange students
move through the airport.
And I always remembered that
in a certain technical sense
even though it was remotely,
that was where we first met.
So, later on, when the tim
came to propose,
I found this app
I could check on
when it was going
to be quiet at that gate,
based on when the planes
were coming and going,
and we were taking
a vacation that day,
so I kind of guided him
into that spot.
I was like, you know,
"Why don't you show me
that spot
where you first were
when we first started
chatting with each other?"
And, just behind, there wa
a little bit of space
behind that gate agent
stand in the window
and I invited him to look
out the window there
and then got on one knee.
I told him it'd be, you know
a lot like being in the airport.
Life with me would be probably
hard to steal private moments,
but also full of adventure
And, luckily for me,
he said yes.
-That's fantastic.
And, considering
how many divorces
have started in O'Hare,
[ Laughter ]
I think it's nice that there's
at least one
[ Laughing ] story
about a marriage starting.
You know, I think one of the -
I should note, by the way,
I had no sense
of what the logo was
for the Department
of Transportation
and I'm noticing it behind you
I feel like, I don't know,
it could be
a little more romantic
than what you guys
are doing right there.
Just put that very much
at the back of your list,
but let's get something
a little flashier.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. I'll Look into it.
-It seems like maybe the job
and the people who've had th
job before you over the year
have focused on things,
maybe primarily
on automobile travel.
It does seem like there is
a shift happening
in this country,
you know, cities
having more bike lanes,
having more pedestrian walkways.
Is that something that you fee
is very much
under your purview as well
-Yeah, and this is
really important to get righ
for safety reasons,
climate reasons,
and a lot of other reasons
You know, there's this old ide
that roads are just for cars
I believe roads are
for human beings
and human beings might be
in a car
or might be on a bicycle
or a scooter
or on foot or in a wheelchair,
and roads need
to support everybody,
however it is
that you get around.
That was a really importan
principle for how we improve
a lot of roadways
in the city of South Bend
when I was mayor,
and I think it's something
that our department
ought to support.
You know, the reality is that --
There's this idea called
complete streets,
but it's about something
even more simple than that
which is just safe streets
and sometimes the safest stree
or the best street is not on
that's just about shooting car
through the middle of
a community as fast as possible.
It's about making sure
people can get
to where they need to go,
safely,
and making sure that our streets
are vibrant
and support us in our lives.
And I think all of us,
especially as we've been
in this pandemic reality,
have had occasion to think
in new ways
about just how much
it means to us
to be in those shared spaces
which is what our streets are.
-It seems like there's
a lot of discussion, now,
about sort of high-tech,
futuristic solutions
to transportation --
super fast tubes
or autonomous vehicles.
How do you both embrace
the possibilities of those
while not losing focus
on the fact that
most people,
certainly in cities,
would just like working buses,
working subways?
-[ Laughs ] Right.
I mean, before we talk
about some of these
really exciting technologies
we've got to take care
of the basics.
Don't get me wrong --
the technologies are compelling.
They're fascinating.
There's a lot going on
with drones delivering
packages right now.
We've got to learn how to deal
with this, as a country --
automated vehicles, hyperloops
magnetic levitation,
you name it.
But, as a mayor,
I also think a lot about thing
like filling potholes,
making sure that our bridges
are in good shape.
And, because this country,
unfortunately,
has systematically failed
to invest
for a very long time,
we're behind.
So, if we want to have the bes
infrastructure in the world,
if America wants to lead
the world
and not be just another country,
then we've got to fix it first
Fix it first,
and be looking ahead
to these future technologies
that are coming, ready or not.
-The present that we're living
in right now, obviously,
due to situations
outside the control
of the Department
of Transportation,
has more -- I should say,
has less commuters
than maybe any time
and, certainly,
the last 50 years.
How does that affect
how you look to the future
not knowing how long
working remotely
is going to be a part of the
American work experience?
-You know,
I think the next normal
is not going to be
like the last one
and we don't yet know
everything that that means
I think, for a lot of employer
and a lot of workers,
the 9 to 5
will never quite be the same
I think it's safe
to say all of us are ready
to not be on Zoom,
not be online,
quite as often as we are,
but that doesn't mean
we're going to snap right back
to the old patterns,
and that means how people
commute might change,
real estate might change,
the way we use our land
might change.
And the reality is there's
no predicting that just yet.
We just got to make sure
we're flexible
and ready to return to something
better than what we had before
-Well, I really appreciate
your time.
Best of luck with all of i
moving forward.
Secretary Pete Buttigieg,
everybody.